Séquence facecam, première.
*Clap*
La dernière fois j'réfléchissais comme ça tout seul, parce que j'ai pas d'ami.
Et j'me disais, tiens y'a plein d'inventions comme ça qui peuvent pas exister
Mais qui pourtant s'raient bien pratiques dans la vie de tous les jours.
On pourrait appeler ça "les inventions imaginaires".
Par exemple, un truc qui s'rait pas mal, ça s'rait un bouton de volume mais carrément sur les gens.
*La personne derrière parle fort*
*Il se tait*
Voilà, donc j'étais vraiment sur la piste en chasse neige, t'sais
Tout le monde me matte genre "alors lui il sait pas ce qu'il fait" tu vois, laisse tomber mon gars...
*plus aucun son ne sort de sa bouche*
Ou alors juste un mode silencieux
sur les bébés.
*le bébé crie fort*
*la femme appuie sur un bbouton et alors le bébé se bet a vibrer*
Allô ?
Un sorte de GPS qui donnerait le meilleur chemin pour esquiver les gens relous.
Dans 5 mètres tourner à gauche pour esquiver Nicolas Corto, le relou du collège qui va vous parler pendant 3 h.
- Hey Norman ! Tu t'rappelles de moi ?
Nicolas Corto 5ème D ! On était ensemble en cours, on sniffait nos prouts ensemble !
Un simplificateur d'explications.
Un truc qui simplifierait tous les trucs trop longs et trop chiants.
- En raison des ayant droits de votre contrat,
si vous souscrivez à notre assurance, le taux d’intérêt sera indexé
* Norman souffle* sur deux ou trois pourcent
En gros j'essaie de t'embrouiller pour que tu signes des trucs qui vont rapporter un maximum de thunes à ma boîte.
Donc soit t'es un gros con et tu signes,
soit t'es un petit peu malin et tu te casses !
Ah bah voilà tout simplement !* il signe*
Une sorte de bracelet électrique à faible puissance
anti mots ringards.
Bon les mecs, ce soir on s'fait une petite soirée à la one again *bruit électrique*
Bah qu'est-ce qui m'arrive ? Je me sens tout flagada *bruit électrique*
Oh non les mecs qui m'a mis ça c'est vraiment un truc de nullos *bruit électrique*
Ah ça commence à m'les briser menu *bruit électrique*
Ah ok, j'ai compris ok, faut dire que des mots à la mode !
Swag !
*bruit électrique*
Un anti-spoiler automatique.
- Tu regardes The Walking Dead toi?
- Ouais je suis à fond dedans en ce moment, j'adore cette série !
*Un casque apparait sur la tête de Norman - J'ai vu le dernier épisode hier c'est ouf,
y'a Glenn qui meurt je m'y attendais pas du tout !
- Désolé j'ai pas entendu.
*bruit de gorge* Ah non ! Y'a Glenn qui meurt !
Y'a Glenn qui meurt ! Il meurt totalement, il décède !
Une application qui serait un Shazam, mais des visages.
- Salut, tu vas bien ?
Tu te rappelles de moi ?
- Oui ! C'est euh...Meuf relou ne jamais parler !
Un truc qui serait très pratique, pour nous les gens qui ont des cernes de huit mètres,
un anticipateur d'insomnie.
- Bon, bonne nuit tout le monde ! J'vais me coucher !  - Bonne nuit !
*voix électronique de femme* - Vous allez faire une insomnie de deux heures en pensant à des trucs badants
tels que votre ex, la mort, ou encore au nombre d'entrées de votre film Pas Très Normales Activités.
- En fait, j'vais rester un petit peu avec vous.
On s'fait un UNO ?
*soufflent et ralent*
*il pleure*
Ou sinon, une sorte d'invention où on pourrait directement euh faire des screenshots mais dans la vrai vie
t'sais un truc que tu kiffes, tu screen direct ! Tu vois ?
- Norman ça existe déjà ça s'apelle une photo ! Hein ?!
T'ES HYPER CON PUTAIN !!
Ce qui serait vraiment cool, ce s'rait une télécommande de télé, parlante.
Elle est où, putain la télécommande, elle est où !
- Mec, mec, psss, chuis là !
Ah salut, ça va ?
Ouais ça va mais merde ça fait trois jours que je suis coincée derrière le coussin !
Et en plus j'ai la voix d'Eddie Murphy, merde !
Euh j'ai une petite question à te poser, ils servent a quoi en fait tous tes boutons là ?
Ah les boutons là *rires* ?! Chais pas...
Une sorte de radar qui te dirait directement où exactement dans le monde
se trouve la femme de ta vie !
*bips* Ah !
Elle est par là !
*musique romantique* Hey femme de ma vie, j'arrive !
*crie de joie* C'est donc elle !?
D'accord, donc une femme girafe !?
Euh t'sais quoi je vais ré-installer Tinder !
Ça s'rait génial s'ils arrivaient à inventer pour de vrai l'hoverboard !
*musique de Retour vers le futur*
- Norman, ça existe déjà en fait.
Ah oui, il faudrait qu'on arrête aussi d'appeler les segways sans guidon des overboards !
Hein, c'est pas du tout pareil, j'suis désolé.
*musique de Retour vers le futur*
J'peux essayer ? Une fois ?!
Une fois, vas-y fais pas ta pute !
Un devinateur de cadeaux.
Mon cœur cette fois j'ai pas pu me tromper, c'est sûr, c'est exactement ce que tu veux.
- Oh ! Un nouveau mec !
- Ah nan mais alors là c'est parfait ! Merci !
En plus lui il a plein d'options j'crois qu'il est mature, attentionné, il est pas radin, il fait des efforts.
- Il fait des efforts ! Nan mais c'est exactement ce que je voulais !
Ouais je sais.
- AH bah non...*cris de joie*
*bruit de bisou et rires*
Ah putain ça me fait plaisir !
- Bonjour !
Voilà j’espère que vous avez kiffé mes petites inventions imaginaires.
Alors certes j'ai pas d'ami mais au moins j'ai des idées...inutiles !
Chuis hyper content parce que vous êtes bientôt 7 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne Youtube.
Ah on y est vraiment très bientôt, là on est vraiment sur le fil.
Merci beaucoup !
Et au fait, qui dit 2016 dit...je re-commence la tournée des Zéniths avec mon spectacle Norman sur scène
en 2016 dans toute l'Europe francophone, en France, en Suisse, et en Belgique.
J'ai déjà hâte d'y retourner de vous revoir dans les Zéniths, ça va vraiment être cool.
A très bientôt en vidéo ou en vrai, ciao !
*musique*
J'crois qu'elle a adoré son cadeau mon gars, écoute...
*cris de plaisir*
Chuis hyper content de moi pour une fois, ouais. J'ai assuré !